you
I wanted to do this since I was about 14
I didn't listen to pop music those
listen to film soundtracks it would be
the works of certainly them John Barry
John Williams Jerry Goldsmith Morricone
I suppose that was the year the late 60s
early 70s the thrill of those those
fantasies that are films coming out and
just think music being such a key part
of that having said that I don't write
that kind of music necessarily now and
those are the sort of projects now as an
adult that I do but that I suppose
that's what it was it was I escaped into
film music traditionally most other
composers I've seen interviewed can it
go oh they saw Star Wars and that was
awesome and I did see Star Wars and it
was awesome but definitely I couldn't
connect myself to that it was just an
awesome thing I remember seeing angel
harp which has got a Mickey Rourke film
with Scott by Trevor Jones there was
something about that they got under my
skin because it was a bit like the
noises I was making in contemporary
dance but I absolutely not made the leap
that I could make these because I was I
was a synth geek so I said like I was
getting whatever cheap since I could
find and breaking them and tried to make
them sort of do funny noises and I just
kind of you know maybe there is a
crossover I always wanted to do film
composing but but to actually get to do
it was kind of really tricky at the
start because you know you're basically
asking people to entrust you with
budgets and their film you know you can
break a lot of things with bad music in
a film it's been so many different jobs
I've done in this industry in film music
you know be orchestrating or programming
or tea-making you know all these things
that actually proved really useful in
the long run I might have read a script
I might even have popped down to a
location to see scenes being filmed but
I come in at a fine cut stage ideally
and we can then talk about what we're
dealing with as a film or as a show if
it's something pre and it would tend to
be you know if there's something's gonna
be played as part of something and
there's going to be shot you might have
to start early on and come up with some
ideas that could be played on set if
there was needed to some directors like
an idea of them
because they can have that in their head
as they shoot and it might influence
various things that's kind of quite rare
but every now and then it comes up over
here there's the perfect creative
process there's the bit where you've
already got a pre-existing relationship
with the director where they send you
the script in advance where you maybe go
down and set you discuss ideas you have
three months to write it you write
during the Kirk maybe you have some more
changes to make and then you have a
luxurious recording and mixing period of
another six weeks so there's that and
then there's what actually happens and
what actually happens is often anything
from ridiculous last-minute phone calls
to like proper jokes just sort of surely
that's not possible
and so you might be looking down the
barrel of I don't know a feature films
of mid 60 minutes of music to write
recommended mix in four weeks sometimes
less often editors and directors will
will lay in what we call temp tracks
which are temporary pieces of music into
a cut just to show an idea of how a
scene should should be working just to
help with retention or with pace or it's
moved so it's rare sadly that we get to
see something without music already laid
in it's only when I get to see things or
there would be an assembled scene or
anything because everything starts to
influence the way the music will be like
whether it be the way it's lit and the
way all the colors of it or the just the
way that the costs use the word
everything seems to have this weird sign
of subconscious thing where all of a
sudden the idea you had from reading the
script isn't quite the one that's going
to resonate with the picture so
sometimes I start early and sometimes
you get asked to come up with the theme
ideas early on but for me it's only when
you're really responding to the actual
image and the way that it's been shot
that's when it starts to make sense
that's when the real work starts
happening we're going to discover many
technological tools which are going to
allow us to give the movie musical as
much realism as when you go to today and
see a war movie or see one of the movies
when he sound effects or you go and see
Life of Pi all this movie which has all
this visual and and and sound effects
which you thought were amazing you think
are amazing and were impossible to do
and I must say that what we are doing
the recording live in this movie was not
possible to do ten years ago there were
the
have not been invented we could not do
what we have done
you know like segregate a pianist in a
kind of glass cage playing on on a scent
and and just with an invisible earphone
in the ear of Hugh Jackman or Anne
Hathaway or Russell Crowe and no one
knows there was any that ear piece in
their ear which is so small today that
no one can see it
but they had it in their ear when they
were singing oh it would not have been
possible so God knows what we're going
to invent in the next five years but
come to my writing room it's it's one of
those you know screens everywhere and
iPads and this and you know it looks
like an apple showroom in there all the
time and yeah and yeah I when i write
tunes i write them on a piano with a
piece of paper and i know that when i'm
reaching for the computer to try and
solve the problem and for a computer i
sound particularly for orchestral music
then I'm pointing in the wrong direction
I really am so I'm part of myself Jenni
at the moment he's trying to shake that
up as much as possible and just just
going to record so play it play live
with some friends and we just record
what we've done but it means that you
can't tweak it in the same way there's
not the same flexibility when the
picture cut changes which it always does
it's already set in stone so it's
responsible for an incredible degree of
productivity that we can do now but also
I think we've musically photocopied the
soul out of what we do there's a
tendency as a composer to to work in
quite a bit of isolation someone who's
like me who's quite big arias I don't
know why I ended up with this job
actually there's been so much time in a
room on my own with a computer so I love
working with real musicians to be able
to bring in some we did the club scenes
and things bring the band in that and
always try and bring in musicians when
we can the music thing is is the element
I do but essentially you're you're more
of a filmmaker who does the music bit so
you're kind of involved in all the same
discussions about storytelling and
character and all of those things to
make the film as good as it can possibly
be and it just so happens that the area
that I kind of help out with is music
but essentially the things you need are
the same as other estimates it's being
part of this team and the collaborator
and
and kind of then this coming into it
without much of an ego really and bit
happy to to keep tweaking away and
changing things and basically pushing it
as far as I can go to make it as good as
it can be